[Captions by Y Translator]
In today's video,
we're going to try to make a lid
for our vacuum chamber that
lets us use our arc welder in a vacuum.
What will happen to the sparks?
What will happen if we
melt something in the vacuum?
[Music]
What's up, guys? Josh here.
If you didn't already know,
we've got brand new merch for sale.
We've got two different
long sleeve shirts,
a new short sleeve shirt,
and for the first time ever,
I think, a phone case.
If you want to check out
this awesome stuff,
click the link
in the description below,
and while you're at it,
comment below and tell me
what your favorite is,
and what you'd like to see in the future,
and maybe we can make that happen.
Guys, we've done
some cool experiments
using a vacuum chamber,
and we have also done
some pretty cool experiments
using our arc furnace.
That runs a ton of electricity
through these carbon rods,
and lets us melt metal.
Well today, we want to see
if we can combine those
by making a lid that
will allow us to use
our carbon rods down
inside the vacuum chamber,
and then we'll see what happens
if we try and melt something
in the vacuum chamber,
assuming we can get it to work.
What's going to be
the difference
when there's no air
around our carbon rods?
What's going to be
the difference between the arc?
How are things going to react,
or melt differently when they're
in a low pressure environment?
That's what we hope to find out.
The idea is pretty simple.
We'll make a new acrylic lid,
but we'll add two holes that
allow our carbon rods
to go inside.
We'll seal those up
with some Proto putty,
and see what happens
if we make an art
inside our vacuum chamber.
To get started,
we've got our vacuum chamber,
and we've got
this same thick pieces
of acrylic that
our original vacuum chamber lid
was cut from.
We're going to cut another one
about the same size,
drill it the same way
we did for this valve,
and then we're going
to add a couple more holes
that will let us put
our carbon rods down
through the lid
into the vacuum chamber.
We'll try and create
some Proto putty seals
that fill those holes,
but hold on to the carbon rod.
So we keep the vacuum
as we use the arc furnace
down inside.
Hopefully, the Proto putty
will be flexible enough
that were also able to move
our rods where we want them,
and have a little bit of control
over what's happening.
[Music]
We've got our whole cut and tapped,
so we should be able to thread
right into it.
We're not going to permanently
attach this yet.
We're still going
to add some thread tape,
and wait until we've drilled
the rest of our holes.
[Music]
That is on there.
We should now able to get
our carbon rods down
inside there.
We're gonna use
Proto putty to sort
of plug up the two holes where
the rods are going down in.
But Proto putty is
a flexible rubber,
so I should still
have the ability
to move them a little bit.
Hopefully, I'll be able
to keep the vacuum seal
while that happens.
[Music]
All right, we've got
Proto putty all the way
around our carbon rods.
Let's let that cure.
[Music]
All right, at this point, we
should have everything set up.
We're going to give
it a quick test
without pulling a vacuum first,
just to make sure that these
are arcing down inside our jar.
Let's give this a shot.
I'm going to say that works.
We got our arc down
inside the jar.
Let's try pulling out all the air,
and see what happens.
[Music]
Good.
We are getting a seal.
What the fog?
That will get pulled
out in a sec.
Okay, now, I'm just going
to try turning it on
from a distance.
[Music]
Oh.
I see smoke.
I think that already began
burning the Proto putty,
but you know what
was interesting is
the arc didn't really do much.
Like I thought, in theory,
the arc should be able to extend
a lot larger in this situation,
but it didn't hold at all.
Let that run
for a minute to pull more,
more intense vacuum if it will.
[Music]
That's a lot of smoking.
The arc in a vacuum
didn't really do too much.
So I decided I wanted
to try something else.
I've poured some liquid nitrogen
into this soda bottle,
and I've got a balloon
over the nozzle.
So as the nitrogen expands
its just filling this balloon.
So what I should have is
a balloon full of pretty
much pure nitrogen,
and I'm going
to see what happens
if I take this balloon,
stretch it over the air intake,
and then let it back in.
That should fill our vacuum
chamber with pure nitrogen.
I'm not going to let it go
all the way to empty,
because I do still
want there to be
suction holding the lid on.
[Music]
All right, almost
pure nitrogen atmosphere.
[Music]
Oh, there's our smoke point.
Arc furnace in a vacuum chamber.
It may need some tweaking
before we can really do
too much with it.
The Proto putty does
a really good job of giving
us a little bit of flexibility.
So we have control while
maintaining a vacuum inside.
But it does tend
to burn pretty quickly.
So we may look into
whether there are
any higher temperature rubber
gaskets we can sort of form
onto there,
It's possible
that with something higher temp,
we might be able to have
longer times where it runs,
and maybe even melt
something down inside.
At this point,
anything that would melt
would have to run so long
that it would start burning
the proto putty.
Proto putty does light on fire
if it gets hot enough.
I don't want to just
burn the proto putty and
then catching the acrylic on fire,
and then the whole studio would burn up.
No one wants that.
It's also possible
that we would have
a different result
if we had a more perfect vacuum.
This vacuum chamber
does not pull a perfect vacuum,
and whatever is left inside,
maybe able to interfere
with how our Arc is forming.
What do you think?
Are there other ideas
you think we should try
with our arc furnace?
Are there other tools you
think we should try and set up,
so that they can be manipulated
while inside a vacuum?
I think that drilling
holes into the top
and making a rubber
or Proto putty seal
does work fairly well.
It was still holding a vacuum,
and I was able
to move these around.
So I might be able
to get some other tools
or something down inside
to be able to move stuff
while under low pressure.
What would you
like to see us do?
Guys, the fun doesn't end here.
We've got more for you to see.
The box at the top
will take you directly
to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box will show
you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next.
And if you hit this bomb
in the middle,
you will be subscribed
to our channel.
That way,
you never miss out on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.